[Music]
today
we got the three muslims
fayette and your boy angel
today we want to talk about music
why the hell is it wrong
why do you all think it's haram before
we start going in like just
subjectively speaking like off the rip
what do y'all think
hi bro islam really advocates for
you just detaching yourself from
anything that you might be addicted to
it might be things that you're
physically forming an addiction to
might be things that you're just forming
a tolerance to so you're making a
depends to it
anything like that so drugs like
substances money
pornography music anything like that so
music believe it or not it is something
that you can form a dependence to
right because people that listen to
music a lot
they'll recognize they can't do anything
without listening to music for example
people that go to the gym and this would
be me too when i would go to the gym i
would have to have my headphones in the
days that i had that i forgot my
headphones
bro i would be ready to just drive back
home and pick up my headphones and come
back
i don't care if it's a 20 30 minute
drive i'm not getting that pumping
second reason is music kind of makes you
not
it just it just makes you off your
square i'm not fully
logical when i'm listening to music i
kind of start feeling
emotions towards what the music is
trying to project you towards
like if i'm listening to some r b best
believe i'm going to think like
i not normally think if i'm listening to
something hype like some trap music i'm
going to be
up and ready to go if i'm listening to
some like
latin music bro is this going to make me
want to go to like cuba
or something like that you feel me so it
just it just kind of
drags me and pulls me off my center
and i don't like that because i like
being in center and being in control but
that's like being grounded
you lie being grounded yeah yeah
what about you about you romney
islamically speaking
for anything to be haram you would need
evidence for it because the formula
basically in islam is everything is
halal until proven
and how do you prove use the quran
so there are certain verses alluding to
it in the quran
um the scholars mention them i they're
stepping my mind i don't really remember
them but they have to do with
um like delusion and delusional
enjoyment
and you know don't give in to delusional
enjoyment all of that all that stuff
but there's a hadith of the prophet
where he said
that all musical instruments are haram
except the arabic drum the ones you
would like here at like
you know islamic weddings and that stuff
but scholars differ over whether it's
authentic or not
so there is a hadith in bukhari where
the prophet said that there will come a
time where my ummah
his people they look to make i believe
it was men wearing silk adultery
alcohol and music they look to make
musical instruments
so if they're looking to make it halal
and he's mentioning it amongst other
haram things
it's a given that it is haram most of
the scholars throughout islamic history
majority of them said it is haram but a
lot of people like to take certain
scholars
and twist what they're saying because
some of them said like you know
singing is haran and poetry is halal and
all of that
and they mix it up with saying okay and
he's saying music but this is not
the case necessarily the majority of
scholarship is haram so that's why
we have that ruling well why do
you think it's haram like the reasons
behind it oh
no no how do you feel about music
okay yeah so as i mentioned to you guys
earlier i actually
used to make music and i used to listen
to music i used to listen to more
lyrical music where it has like you know
proper meaning like kendrick lamar and j
cole and you know there's a message but
it actually has like it sounds proper
and i used to listen to that i used to
try and make that kind of music so i was
heavily invested in it
and i feel like a lot of people use it
as like a coping mechanism that's why a
lot of people when
they go through a breakup they start
listening to breakup songs and stuff
or when when they're at the gym they
have to listen to workout music there
are literally playlists on youtube
called workout music
and all this stuff that hypes you up and
it's kind of like they they need that
because what they don't have it within
themselves
they need an emotional song because they
can't you know cope with it emotionally
and by themselves
so people use it as a means of
short-term gratification
and it becomes like an addictive thing
to some people because they use it to
get over things and i wouldn't say
that's necessarily healthy
or helpful especially compared to other
means
and also things like you know when you
start listening to music
you start dancing and that stuff you
were mentioning before you become
submissive to the music and all that you
kind of submit to it
um hold on too far ahead bro
this is
yo by the way everyone he has a
soundcloud we're going to put a link in
the description box down below
why don't you tell us what is what his
name was
uh i actually forgot what was it it was
a little queasy
oh lil queasy a little queasy on the
beat
queasy baby yeah a little queasy
all right that's joke it wasn't little
queasy nobody think that
how many followers did you have on
soundcloud at your peak i'm talking like
this is like my
the epiphany where i don't like you i
could do something out of this
i don't remember didn't you tell me that
you were gonna
make a tick tock like with your rapping
but you decided
no i'm gonna do it for islam
i was gonna make a poetry thing and i
wasn't gonna post like poetry stuff on
there and i decided i'd rather just keep
it for islamic
purposes um true i was joking but that's
that's pretty cool
he actually has a book that he wrote he
is an author he is a
number one new york times best-selling
author
he's gonna get it's gonna be like
misleading information at the bottom of
the video
it doesn't even matter at the end of the
day anyone can write a book and it'll be
a new york times number one
that title itself doesn't mean much but
all that matters
bro i'll approve your book
have i read it yeah or you ask him in if
he's read his own book
why would i ask him if he read his own
book hey sometimes you gotta ask bro you
ain't drake bro
i'm asking you you're right you're right
uh
nah baby i have not ready yet but send
me the link and send me the soundcloud
link as well
bro yo so you said
a very nice example you said that
people use as a coping mechanism like
when they're going through a breakup
can both of y'all give examples of a
time
where you use music as a coping
mechanism
i can i can okay
bro so this this is actually quite
unfortunate because this is after this
is when i was practicing
i was a practicing muslim alhamdulillah
this was
just over a year ago this song came out
i forgot i forgot his name
i think it's nightfall or something i
forgot the artist
he's some white guy yeah yeah
but it's basically lyrics depressing
yeah it kind of was it kind of was and
it was basically about a girl leaving
him or something
and just over a year ago i went through
i don't know what should i call a
breakup i call it a breakup i'll call it
a breakup
people are gonna be like oh my god he
had a girlfriend and no no
that was a failed business transaction
fax
fact failed business transaction my
manager did not look into it enough
i fired him all right but carry him i'll
carry on yeah
but on a real note i listen that was the
first time i really listened to music in
a while and i kept listening to it
singing it as well and all this stuff
and yeah it sounded good but i had a
message behind it as well
and that's what really impacted me
because i was in this emotional state
and i used it to cope with it and
felt like i don't know i couldn't really
describe it it's just something that i
did
uh but looking back it's kind of like
there are so many ways to go but
especially as a muslim there's so many
ways to go about it
that are more productive that's all i
done answer man
um i'm gonna just be honest with y'all
because you know this isn't something
like
when you go to a church and you're
trying to go you know be a proper
christian and you confess
into the to the pastor now we don't do
that in islam but the reason i'm telling
you guys is because generally for
education purposes guys i'm trying to
like
have y'all learn from my mistakes and
y'all learn from our mistakes
as a collective so i don't mind telling
you um i used to be addicted to weed
not addicted in the sense that i'm like
some like
you know i'm i'm trying to like sell an
arm and a limb but like i used to i used
to smoke a lot of weed
um and at least to my standards and it
got to a point where i was like okay
this is bad
i gotta abstain now believe it or not
when i quit
it's been almost two years since i quit
but i'm the luck
when i quit i used to be having such a
hard time being present
in the moment and my mind would be
wandering i would have a lot of anxiety
a lot of weird symptoms stuff like that
from the withdrawal
and believe it or not your boy used
music
as a coping mechanism to force me to be
present
to the present moment and to just be in
the now
because there was something about just
being in my head having all these
feelings like anxiety depersonalization
and all that and i was just like
really weird and really wonky and
something told me one day just
listen to music because what would i
what what what i would either do
would be just run or go on a walk or do
something that physically makes me in my
body
or listening to music and as soon as i
listen to music it kind of comforted me
where it was like i feel good i feel
present but then it got
maladaptive to the point where it's like
without the music
my anxiety from quitting weed was higher
so now i was like okay i'm not going
back to smoking weed why don't i just
use music isn't it better than me
and i went into this whole week to
month-long process where i just
i listened to a lot of music
well let me just say i'm proud of you
man
for quitting weed and
i don't know if you quit music yet but
proud of both of you for
quitting music it's a very tough thing
um but to carry on to carry on guys
because
i'm pretty sure people are like yo what
the hell
how is it hot on bro y'all keep talking
all right so
good examples by the way good examples
music is haram and
this is uh subjectively speaking here
we'll let you guys
uh think about this on your own and
make your own connections and come to
the answers yourself because i
you know obviously we can't we can't say
everything to be 100 the truth
you have to find that for yourself and
let allah
lead you and guide you to the answers so
in my opinion if someone would ask me
why is music all right based on
also what you guys said i'm a piggyback
here
add on to this all right so before i
actually came to islam
i was doing a dopamine detox and that's
the time where i stopped listening to
music
before that i was just like y'all
listening to music a lot
i didn't have no uh music booth and a
soundcloud
ready to go but um i was definitely
definitely listening to music for sure
for sure um
and i remember doing this dopamine detox
and thinking to myself oh man i can't
believe i'm not gonna
be able to listen to music and i
remember like one week past two week
past three weeks past
and i noticed like i was just becoming
more peaceful
and i was becoming more present and i
was like well that's
that's strange because like
i would personally say that when i
listen to music
i feel a little bit more present because
it made
it made my body move right it made me
maybe dancing made me feel some type of
weight whatever emotion whatever
message was being uh transmitted
through the music it was making me feel
that and bro
music releases dope me so obviously it's
going to make you
feel a little bit more present it's like
fire when he stopped smoking weed
he started listening to music it had a
very similar effect because it's
dopamine
so it allowed him to feel semi-normal
for lack of better words right
so i started noticing that i started
becoming more peaceful
and i started asking myself well damn
like is music
really something that should be listened
to i mean
yes it feels good but i can
inherently say that i feel a hundred
times better now that i'm not listening
music
and then that's when i started looking
more into it and i started looking into
the effects of music and
guys i might be butchering this
tremendously but i think
there's um either a study or something
done if i can find it i will for sure
link it in the description box but it
says
that music affects
both of your nerves you have two types
of nerves that
i i do not remember but the way that it
affects it
is that it it alters
your brain chemistry it's it's something
like that dude i'm not remembering
any of it right now no i remember you
shared that article and it like it just
takes you out of your logic
[Music]
i mm-hmm what i'm trying to say with all
the is that
after doing research and now that i
can't remember i'm stumped i'm
definitely gonna go
look and find it and put it in there but
after doing the research and seeing for
myself
all right yeah i guess i guess music
isn't the best thing and then coming
into islam and then
seeing that music is haram that music is
forbidden
and then it's like seeing the
explanations that people had and like
the explanation that romney said in the
beginning
and if you think about it like again
what happens when you listen to music
in the first few seconds your body
starts moving
that right there is submission it is
confusion of the highest order your body
is literally submitting to the music
instead of allah
and guys not not to get crazy crazy with
this but if you submit to the music
you are literally accepting whatever is
being transmitted in the music
yeah because at like nightclubs and
stuff you can't have a nightclub without
music or you can't have a party without
music
so there's a reason they play music in a
certain type of music at parties
so yeah subhanallah it's that same type
of vibe guys
and yo fyi i'm not out here telling you
guys i used to smoke weed and then i had
this and that
just for just for fun all right like
i genuinely you know when i quit weed
i had a lot of f symptoms like anxiety
depersonalization depression whatever
you want to name it
and it took me about six months where i
was messed up
and this was about a year and a half ago
and or two years ago and when i had this
in this period of time i realized a lot
of things about mental illnesses and
disorders
i realized all these symptoms we have
today in society it's
hella over you know diagnosed over
classified
and most mental illnesses and symptoms
that you guys feel day-to-day
if you guys do they're all kind of one
and they're stemming from one
issue so not to you know toot my own
horn or anything but
since then i probably have dozens of
people that came to me for the same
exact thing that they've been going
through
usually accompanied by weed and i helped
them throughout
um and helped them out of it and i'm
pretty qualified i'm not like a licensed
you know psychologist or anything like
that but trust me like i have a lot of
experience i don't know what i'm talking
about
so if any of you guys are going through
the same thing um kind of addicted to
weed anything like that
you guys know exactly where to find me
everything stays between us
if you want to get your mind right um
but yeah aside from that i wanted to add
something to multi-hot points
when i would do i never did a dopamine
fast like my boy angel
but i did something where i kind of just
refrained from music for a few days
i think i talked to you about it last
year and you were like yo do a music
fast
and what i did was i remember on day
four there was something about it i just
felt so clear
so peaceful i could just focus and be in
the present and i preferred it over
in the state where i was listening to
music now here's where things are fine
i was driving and i'm pretty sure
everyone listens to music when they
drive
right what i'm trying to say is everyone
that does listen to music definitely
listen to it when they drive
so as i'm driving i'm like i literally
have my finger on the play button and
i'm like okay it's been four days
whatever
i'm just like bro if i click play
i don't want it to like undo the state
that i feel now i don't want to be like
sunk back
in and i feel like everyone when they
try to like abstain from anything that
they know they shouldn't be doing
they feel that cross or that fork in the
world where they're like
i really want to stop doing this and i'm
this close to like rebounding or
relapsing back
and they're almost like afraid of
success they're afraid of like just
continuing their thing
continuing their dopamine fast or music
streak or whatever you want to say
and believe it or not i didn't i didn't
click play
i kept going i went about two or three
weeks without listening to music
and dog that was insane it was
refreshing
i had so much time where i was more
aware of things around me i was more
present when i was driving
i was noticing things that i didn't
notice before about the roads and
everything
when i was in the gym i was having a
non-muscle connection that i couldn't
when i was listening to music
and i noticed that when i didn't have
music before i would be weaker
so i kind of broke that addiction you
feel me
[Music]
hmm
how do you feel about that sir romney
honestly
but subscribe it's good to be here so i
feel like if anyone's watching this and
they have you know they listen to music
often
even if it's just to experiment see what
it would be like they should pause it
for like a week or so
and see the difference because if you
care about yourself and your well-being
do do the most minimalistic thing and
just
cut it out for at least a few days if
you truly care about yourself then at
least try it
because they can't it can't hurt
you're right man people are always
wondering how do i know if i have a a
pornography problem or a music problem
or a substance problem okay and it's
like go a week without it
see how you feel if you feel some type
of way by day seven and you can't focus
and you can't go without it
you're addicted to it and by addicted
we're not talking about physically
addicted like
you're like shaking without it not it
could be psychologically addicted too
like you have a dependence on it so now
without it you feel some type of way
and you need it just to feel the same
yeah subhanallah
and just think about it like this
because we talked about you mentioned
dependency right
would you rather be dependent on 100
things or
independent as much as a human can be
independent bro 100
yeah because if you're dependent on all
these different things what happens if
one goes wrong
if you don't have access to one or
something like that exactly it's all
it's kind of like
all those people that really rely on
people i'm not trying to be some like
bitter black
person but i'm generally telling you
guys like one of the biggest things i
see today is people rely on other people
not just things like music or whatever
but
we rely on things too much and we don't
realize that relying on them is a
problem like angela was talking about
music
and you guys already know the biggest
problem is not knowing you guys have a
problem to begin with
which is why i was talking about these
dopamine fast and things like that
it really cemented the idea that it's
really hard to
live life and go day to day withdrawing
from all the things that we think
we're not addicted to like no technology
no music
it seems like it's undoable yeah
it's kind of long damn man it goes deep
then
it goes deep yeah yeah that goes very
deep
above goes man
and like now i'm just remembering so i'm
still stumped on that one
study thing bro like i can't believe i
can't remember anything bro
no one of the things that said one of
the things it said
was um when it affects your body
it also affects mental state like you
were saying right
and bro like it said that
in the u.s or like in places where music
is most
dominant most seen where you guys like
it's in the culture like you go
anywhere you go to the grocery store
there's music you go to the bathroom
there's
music you go to the park there's music
how the hell is there music in the park
i don't know but there's music
oh and these cultures where there's so
much music playing
it actually has the highest cases of um
and what's it called it starts with the
end bro
i can't believe it bro i can't believe
it
that's somebody bro nah someone take
over i'm
i'm done no i know what you mean bro all
right this here's what's weird bro
i'm i'm actually fascinated you brought
that up when i was in those four days
when we were talking you were like yo
try music fast for these couple days
i was like i bet easy enough right see
what i thought
was i didn't you know this is before i
realized i'm living in this
joha culture bro in canada just like you
said bro
i thought okay cool easy but i just
gotta stop listening spotify my phone
stop listening to music in the car stop
listening to music at the gym
and then before you know i was like a
man's gotta eat a man's gotta get some
protein at the grocery store so i'll go
to the grocery store and get some food
huh what do you know there's music there
i'm like man i'm not even trying to do
this
um some of my credit card got got uh
closed down
or or blocked and i had to call them to
authorize it again
so i called credit card company and then
they didn't even ask me like
do you want to listen to music or do you
want to listen to nothing it just said
your wait time is x and then where you
hear music
issues music i'm at the park just like
this man said
how is there music in the park where is
the sound coming from
allahu allah bro yeah music and it's
like before you know i was like
i could do so much to take music out of
my control
but it's like it's they live in a
society where it's normalized and
ingrained into the culture deep
so you're right man yeah and the way
that i was looking for was neurotic
illnesses
so issues up here stemming from
your psychology your psychological state
the places where music is most prevalent
those are the places that have the most
mental institutions
to treat neurotic illnesses and then
places where music is
not very prevalent or music is just
nowhere in sight for the most part they
have the lowest
mental institutions because they have
the lowest cases of
mental neurotic illnesses tell me
tell me right now if that is not
something that just blows your mind it
does
i'm gonna play doubles advocate bro not
to just rain on your parade but
i took this course when i was doing my
undergrad at mcmaster and
it was called music therapy and trust me
bro
your boy has no experience with that i
took it because it was a bird course
which is essentially a course you take
to boost your gpa you don't really care
about it my major was bio so i was just
like yeah i just want to get the hell
out
keep this as an elective took music
therapy so we had a
registered music therapist as our prof
and she was out here
you know preaching some whole other
level stuff and bro
at the end of the course i realized
there's this whole profession called
music
therapy where they literally use music
to treat illnesses and neurotic problems
like anxiety and all that have you guys
heard
about that no i haven't but what do you
all think about that
like in terms of using music to heal
neurotic illnesses what music
technically causes a lot of neurotic
illnesses
well i already know what i learned at
the end of it it was the same thing i
realized from anecdotal first time
experience with the substances
bro music takes away
your attachment and dependence to a
problem
but it unknowingly causes another
problem now but it doesn't
seem like a problem because society
ostracizes
marijuana and drinking and all that but
nobody ostracizes music
matter of fact you're weird for not
listening to music
yeah you're weird for driving in silence
so
i feel like these people definitely have
issues with music after that but they
don't realize
it's a problem
every girl i've been with in the past
used to hate that i used to drive
without music
bro if i'm being honest if i'm being
honest
when i think about like marriage and all
that and like you know driving with your
wife or whatever
all i can think about no matter no
matter where my mind wanders to all i
end up thinking about is
driving in the car and having to say i
don't listen to music we're gonna play
quran
or something and them just being like
wait what the heck
i don't know why but you mentioned this
i was like
down has that happened to you you've got
to know
that bob's with the energy bro yeah yeah
that is true man one of the previous
questions
she says that you just gotta stop the
car in the middle of the road and just
tell her to get out
100 man yeah
that's not real but hold up honestly
you talking to me you're talking around
me i'm talking to you bro
once or twice oh you talking about
me driving in the car with a and no
music
yeah then kicking kicking to check out
oh bro come on don't put me on the spot
hmm
anyways continuing on
so music using music if music is hard
music can cause neurotic illnesses
why is it that sometimes it's used as a
healing modality and
i don't i i probably didn't say it in
this video but we tried recording this
what like
7 8 12 times i'm pretty sure in one of
them
i was saying that um you can have
different
frequencies of music and i'm not talking
about the hippie stuff i'm talking about
legitimate frequencies
of the music where you can have like the
432
i think it's five five something maybe 5
32 or something like that
definitely don't remember it off the rip
but there's there's different
frequencies
and that's a fact and each one has a
different effect on the human body so
what would one say to someone trying to
counter argue
saying that ah but you have a healing
frequency like how can that be haram if
it's
if it's healing the body if it's a
healing frequency
um well from my experience you healing
one
sensitivity to one frequency means by
definition you're harming your
sensitivity to the other frequencies
would that just mean what do you think
um
i was gonna say is it pure
like purely helpful or is it still
creating
a dependency or another issue in the
background because even with like
physical medication actual medication
that you take there's a whole list of
possible side effects that's actually
very interesting that you brought that
up i just have a quick question for you
yo angel can i see your dp real quick
doesn't that make you gay
romney carry on all right so
even with actual medication that anybody
takes there's certain side effects
that they may experience from it but
it's still medication it's still meant
to treat them or heal them or help them
so if there are still you know um
side effects i'd call them of listening
to music as a
healing method then this isn't exactly
helpful especially if there are other
methods
of healing but obviously i haven't
studied this i haven't looked it up so
i'm not
too sure of that and also how how's the
prophet saw i said i'm
really gonna communicate 1400 years ago
okay but if you listen to this frequency
then you're okay but every other
frequency is not okay and is that really
i don't know a lot of people wouldn't
even really consider that music
especially like present-day music
yeah but that would be more like it
literally just be more of just a
frequency literally
yeah because when you say one frequency
it's like
i mean i don't know i don't know yeah i
don't know i think i just confused all
of us on that one
no man trust me there was that 432 hertz
i listened to a lot of music and broke
there's something about that made you
feel some type of way
there was also like what they do is they
make like these slowed and reverb type
music where it's like
they take a song and they they change
the frequency where the duration stays
the same but it changes the frequency
so believe it or not guys i don't know
if any of you guys have heard any songs
where
they take the song and they make it
slowed and what they do
is the duration's the same so the entire
feeling or sensation of it feeling slow
motion is entirely changed on the
frequency
and the vibration of the music nothing
changed with the duration of the song
spooky stuff man yeah i really like what
you said too
about that you're healing yourself on
one frequency
but you're harming yourself on another
all right so are there any points you
guys want to make on music specifically
because there's a whole other
there there are a plethora of things
that people use to cope or are addicted
to
in our societies that may be affecting
them
and i think it goes back to short-term
gratification versus long-term
gratification
yeah let's get into that right so
so yeah let me let me be done
listen a second let me see that hold up
hold up before before your daddy
for your daddy i had a quick thing
we talked about weed you guys can answer
this after all now goes but
well i mainly talked about weed dude
let's talk about wheat
any of y'all if y'all had any experience
with weed if you don't want to say you
remember this is not
catholicism this is not a church you
don't gotta you know be like some
trinitarianism
type of vibe where you gotta confess
your life and to another creation of god
which i find absurd
but that's just me if you wanna share
with the viewers cool
if not no worries but i know you guys
don't partake
but how do you part partaking in wheat
romney i'm gonna take it first all right
all right
all right so guys first and foremost
we say these to drive the examples home
we do not say this to boast or to be
prideful
over the things we've done these are our
mistakes these are
the things that we have fallen and we
needed to press life alert
get back up you know we're here so we're
explaining to you guys what what
happened right so don't take it as like
we're being
um prior for both for over what we've
done we're just sharing this
to drive on the example so exactly
oh man dude oh man let me tell you all
about this all right so
i started smoking in high school
and the reason i started smoking was
literally
because everybody else was doing it
literally like all my friends were doing
it and i remember my best friend at the
time
comes up to me he's like bro have you
ever got an
eye i was like no he's like bro bro
neither have i we're gonna do it
tonight i was like all right let's do it
dude i remember doing that and like
not even to talk about the experience
because like yeah some of it might have
been cool some of it might have been bad
but it's like
the the point of the story is that the
wii
just kept me in this state where it's
like when i was sober i could only think
about my experiences while i was high
and it made me want to go and be high
again and again
and again and
it just it made me it made me lack
presence like whenever i was
completely sober and someone was talking
to me
the only thought that i had in my head
was like man if i was high right now
yo tell me i'm wrong but psychosocial
or psychoanalytically everyone just
wants to recreate that first high
tell me i'm wrong every time you got you
wanted to get high you just wanted to
feel like that first time but bro
you're never gonna get that first high
yeah you're never gonna get the first
eye and just bro just to throw it out
there on the side no
i spoke about this in my video where you
know i was talking about my revert
to islam and about the feeling that i
had
once i accepted is um
after reading the quran and how that
just made everything else fail in
comparison
to what i've done like all the things
that i've done and like i said i'm not
proud of it
but all those things i've done it it
failed in comparison and like fire said
like when you do these things you're
always chasing that first high
and yo from personal experience right
now
like what i felt the first time after i
accepted
like internally that islam was the truth
and that allah was the creator and
muhammad peace be upon him was
and is the final messenger you guys like
i still feel that
i still feel that first feeling even
when i'm praying when i'm super focused
so like
subhanallah like here i am i don't have
to chase anything
i'm experiencing it every single time
and every time i experience it
it's better than every other time that
i've done any of these other things
i think that's crazy it doesn't matter
but i think it's crazy it's amazing
though how like shaytan
knows he can't get us when we're in our
grounded state when
we're in our logic so he uses all these
different things to get us off our
square
whether it be weed music alcohol
gambling
different types of addictions just so
we're just not
grounded and detached from the world and
we're attached and then he uses these
things we're attached to
to just further spiral us into
dysfunction subhan allah
firstly on him may allah bless you
immensely that was beautiful
it goes back to the verse in the quran
the two verse in the quran
where allah says those who believe
and whose hearts are content with the
remembrance of allah
indeed with the remembrance of allah
their hearts find ease and contentment
and i feel like a lot of people are
trying to find highs
and happiness up here but what they need
is contentment
because if you look at the definition of
contentment
it has happiness in the definition
because a person is content
and what's better what's a better
mechanism
to be content about anything literally
anything
than the remembrance of the one who has
control over everything
when you submit to the one who is
controlling all of your affairs
you don't need to go to music that only
impacts you
but doesn't really change anything
externally
but allah has control over everything
internally and externally
from your own perspective and then
there's another verse
really quickly there's another verse
where allah says
that without the remembrance of allah
a person would have a depressed life so
when a person has a depressed life
what do they do they try and find that
high and then they go to music and they
go to drugs and they go to
pornography and they go to women and
they go to friends and they go to all
these things
for short term gratification and it
gives them a sense of gratification
in the moment and that's the high they
experience and then when it's done
they've formed a dependency on it like
we talked about and they want it again
and then when it's done they want it
again and it eventually gets old and
they go to something else and eventually
they run out of things to try
they run out of things to try nothing
gets them
high again like we talked about no one
experiences that first high and
eventually it all just becomes
drowned out so what they need is
long-term gratification where you may
struggle a bit in the beginning
but long term it is so beneficial for
you
guys here's the thing thank you so much
for sharing that but
i just wanted to say that the quran
tells you like straight up oh mankind
avoid substances avoid intoxicants avoid
all these things
although they bring some benefit in
large by and large
in the grand scheme they bring a lot of
harm and it's true because if you think
about it
just like rami said short term what do
you what do you feel you feel cooked
short term you feel peaceful short time
you feel like i'm on cloud nine i got
that high like you said
but long term what's happening you're
digging yourself deeper
into the grave you're digging yourself
deep dysfunction
yeah bro show us that picture bro just
to drive it home you already know
and yeah there you go
um i wish you had one of pasta bro but
whatever
so that's the point man i get it
at the end of the day bro it's it just
it just
it just makes it suck bro you just
deeper into this addiction
and you're you have more problems to
deal with one problem no
think about it allows us to stay away
from gambling what does gambling do yeah
you might win money every now and then
i've heard of people that have families
and you know children and wives and it's
like
they lost all their money and it's like
what is the point of that bro
so allah tells you plain and simple like
avoid these things like
it's from the devil there's no point
doing these things
they'll just get you further deeper into
these other
issues now we're not going to talk about
pornography in this one guys if you're
wondering but
because i feel like that that that
should be dedicated to a whole separate
episode on its own
we got we got stuff to say about that
how far why are we into this one
i'm not gonna check bro cuz if i
check i'm gonna see my battery
percentage and i don't wanna see that
right now bro
but anyway as i was saying so
to reiterate substances by and large
we don't condone substances
we can them substances if you are
obviously this goes without saying but i
want to reiterate our points and values
if you are suffering right now with the
substance use problem or substance abuse
problem
seek professional help this is not
supposed to replace medical advice
if you're out here genuinely coping or
genuinely having addiction to things
get help all right but with that being
said
we should all strive as angel made a
video about that
to live a sober and peaceful life
right thanks now for those of y'all that
haven't seen this video
go watch that video but right now why
don't you reiterate your main key points
from that
uh to be honest i do not remember that
was years ago but what i will say
to drive home this uh example is that it
all boils down to
submission what are you submitting to
at the end of the day because we all
submit to something
are you submitting to the creator or are
you submitting to a woman
or if you're a woman are you submitting
to a man are you submitting to music are
you submitting to alcohol
are you submitting to weed are you
submitting to shrooms
it's cocaine like what is it what are
you submitting to
and to be honest with you if you like
doing recreational things like speaking
from personal experience
you are submitting to those things
because when you smoke weed it puts you
in a submissive state
literally it puts you in a submissive
state try smoking weed
and then being a hundred percent all
right to where you have
no thoughts going on yet i'm not saying
no thoughts
whatsoever
something too i just wanna tell you
something too um
it's such an umbrella term at the same
time because people don't realize but
all those people that you could think of
like all those rappers
whatever they're also addicted to drugs
at the same time bro
they're addicted to music obviously
they're addicted to drugs they're
addicted to like uh women
and it's a stereotype basically cliche
but at the same time it's rich
bro
can you even see him no no i just see
black like
i just see black bro okay yeah but go on
go under yourself whatever bro
i'm gonna go on i hope he comes back
though but you guys get what i mean
um i know where to be fine though stay
tuned guys
he's back oh i see you bro
i was burning bro i was burning up man i
was sweating
anyway guys what i was saying is all
these people addicted something and it
brings me back to like those days i
would smoke weed and get high
i would never smoke weed and then just
ended there what else would i do i would
always listen to music
i would always over consume television
and
netflix and all that i would over
consume food
and it would be the worst food bro when
you get that munchies you already know
what i'm talking about and it's like
that one dependence and overindulgence
led to other things
isn't that crazy yeah subhanallah
that's usually how it works like it
doesn't i feel like with when it comes
even when it comes to drugs there's a
reason they call weed the gateway drug
right because nobody just
generally they don't just jump to
something hardcore it starts off with
something light
and then they move on then they move on
and then move on you can look at this as
you know short-term gratification
um for different products or different
things
right it could start with music and then
it could turn to something completely
unrelated and then
make its way to women and then
pornography and then draw yeah
bro i wonder because they're always
looking for that yeah
i mean bro women are naturally
submissive like women are naturally they
have more feminine energy which is
submissive by nature
so i'm just saying straight from
personal experience most women i have i
know in my life
are more like i know more women addicted
to weed and all those
you know substances that do those things
then guys i know unless they're like a
super feminine guy who's like
not masculine not on his purpose not
doing his thing
because i don't know any guy that's like
on his path that has time to like do
anything that takes them off his path
and by that i mean takes them
into a more feminine submissive state
you feel me
women though they have that it could be
a gift it could be a curse
they're more naturally submissive which
makes them easily more
you know predisposed to being vulnerable
to these things
but they also have the gift in the sense
that if they're submitting to something
else that's
proper functional and valuable
then by default they're not submitting
to music and drugs and all that
because they can't submit to a lot of
different things at the same time
so if they're out here really focusing
on their iman
or their family or whatever you're not
submitting to the other thing
by nature mendo is the same thing if
they're submitting to we and music and
alcohol and all that they're not on
their purpose they're
not submitting to allah the creator who
has ordained for them
their purpose yeah [ __ ] that's facts
i mean dude bro some some people will
say as well like oh but
i like smoking weed because when i smoke
weed
it makes me have these crazy ideas where
i make all these connections
and i have these realizations and
they'll say that about
mushrooms as well they'll say that about
lizzie and bro some people will even say
oh i like
listening to music sometimes because
music allows me to make certain
connections
and then have realizations but it's like
dude
you'll have those realizations on your
own time
when you are ready allah will show you
the way but if you use these things
you will receive way too much too soon
it's like you pick up the phone
you ask god a question god gives you the
answer
and instead of you hanging up the phone
you're staying on the phone and you
can't hang it up
because you just did a substance that is
now in control of you
you are in submission to this substance
and you
are for lack of better words a slave to
the high
to whatever it is that you have taken
you have to
stay there with the phone up you don't
want the phone to be up but you got the
phone up still
and you're going to be receiving all
these things that you're not going to be
able to process bro because when i used
to smoke and i used to do these things i
used to have these realizations
bro a year would pass two years would
pass
and then i would be able to process it
so it's like what's the point bro
at that point mm-hmm
anytime i did shrooms too it's like it
it forces you
into this higher enlightened state where
you're more receptive to all these
things but it's just short and lived
and you're not ready for that it's
almost like as buddhists call unearned
wisdom
in life and it's like when you come back
and you you're on the come down
you go right back to your life bro it's
not you're not woke or anything you're
not changed for anything
and it's like now you just have this
experience that you're cool and it's
like oh i learned a lot about myself and
now it's like
okay you want to go do it again and
obviously that leads to other things
yeah you ain't get it man you didn't
learn anything bro you
you seen a glimpse of what you could
have had properly but
you decided you want to taste in a free
sample and
you want to go back to your messed up
life
i will go as far as to say that like
when you do substances
that take you out of like your natural
state of mind
that's that's kind of like you trying to
play god that's kind of like you
trying to do things on your time when
it's like
dude there is no
planner that is better than a lot like
allah is the best surprise
allah's plan is greater than our plan
and when we try to take control and we
say ah well
this is my plan this is what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna do this i'm gonna have
these realizations i'm gonna have these
connections like
all right yeah you might have a few of
them but
are you ready for it you're going
against the grain
it's going to be an uphill battle for
life is that something really you want
to do
you want life to be simple guys life can
be super simple
and super easy it's just like going like
god
it's corny but it's true because anytime
i try to be
god um in the sense that i try to be in
control of everything
i just realized one you're not in
control so
anything could happen that reaffirms
that you're not in control and then
you'd be bugging and tripping on
ah why didn't go my way why didn't go to
my expectations
and things are never going to go to your
expectations so
forget it i feel like just a piggyback
off what on hill said before
it's kind of like how you piggybacking
him if he's piggybacking off
you i yeah he got him each other bro
he he got off my back yeah yeah we
piggyback off each other you know
um but yeah it's like yeah made me
forget my point man
so it's like it begs the question
how many more connections would they
have made
if they did it naturally by natural
means if they you know look to expand
their minds
and to reflect on certain things without
any
neurological hindrances or without any
drugs or anything that changes them
what would you know how much more could
they have achieved
and the skills they could have gained if
they had sat down and perhaps meditated
or if they sat down and reflected or if
they made a notebook of certain things
and then connected the dots
and at the end of the day if you think
about our plan what is our plan
our plan is what we want to happen but
what happens
is what allah plans and the only time
our plan goes correctly is
when it's in line with what allah
planned
so mufti actually i think he made a
tweet or he said once
um when he makes a plan and it goes
correctly he says alhamdulillah
once he thanks god once but when it goes
wrong he thanks god twice because not
only did it
not work out for him it worked out for
god's plan
so he thanks god for hindering his plan
which wasn't correct
and he thanks god again for planning and
making it correct
like that yeah it's kind of long i know
i love that
these are gold but guys no no
neurological hindrances bro 19
that's crazy man the future is bright
ladies he's single just just just a
question just a correction just a
question i'm 20.
oh when you're 10 20. uh recently yeah
august
okay bro you've been telling us you were
19 for like the past
few weeks that's not true i didn't say i
was 19.
yeah you did but what did i say in your
defense
it's this thing people do when it's like
when you just turn
an age a number but it's like you're
still in that year
and most of that year you've been saying
you're 19. so you're still 19.
like if people ask me how old am i well
i'm going to say i'm 22.
i'm not actually 23 but i turned did i
actually say
did i actually say i was 19. that's not
the thing you were nineteen
damn that's tough oh my god
a little queasy not queasy
man yeah i'm twenty august and are you
are you looking at what
am i looking
is this the podcast for that no but it
doesn't matter
bro go ahead all right high quality oh
my god
oh my god you're on the spot bro you on
the spot now
all right hype we're getting sonia up in
here bro
high quality first and foremost the
processing of said character and dean
and this is something i'm in full
agreement with
if your character is on point proper
manner and her islam is on for her
diesel point then she understands how
she's supposed to be as a wife
especially islamically which is super
important because i don't want to i
don't want to marry a feminist
i don't want to marry them oh my gosh
bro i don't i don't want i'm not going
to marry someone in sha allah i'm not
going to marry someone who's going to
try and be the man because
allah says in the quran the man is the
male is not like the female the man is
not like the woman
so when one tries to become the other
it's like
where is this coming from you're gonna
have confusion up the highest order
you said about pause before you continue
though what romney referred to when he
was talking about
not this episode is just the episodes
because we're really going to go into
these topics
over there we're going to talk way more
in depth about what he's talking about i
don't want to
you know marry a girl that's going to
try to be the man yeah
i don't blame most sisters today because
most men don't know how to be men
anymore
so we do have part of the blame bro why
they feel like they gotta step up
but i get you it's like if you are doing
what rami is saying
we should do as men then she has no
reason to act like that
if yeah she still is acting that yeah
then then she's like feminist like
that
yeah but since we're on the topic just
to tie it back to the point a lot of
people also use relationships
and a lot of men like to use women as
their
their high their coping mechanism they
use it as a short-term gratification
tool as the device and this is an issue
for many reasons because once you start
using it in that sense you start
idolizing it
and for a man to idolize a woman in that
way he starts giving her
constant attention and affection and all
of this stuff
and then that's when it falls apart
because once you start doing that
me knowing from experience it literally
goes to hell
and that's not something that anybody
wants in a relationship so we shouldn't
idolize relationships we should
utilize relationships thanks so much i
like that bro
exactly bro i feel like a woman gets
fulfillment
with like you being on your purpose this
is just what i i've noticed about from
experience like
women don't want you when you're not
doing something else yeah they might say
they want you to focus on them and give
them their
all of your time but just do that and
watch how they act it's not going to be
how they act when you're on
your thing bro when you're doing things
when you get a raise
when you get into a program they feel
happy too they tell their friends about
it they tell the world about it
they feel successful when you're
successful for us it's not the same
it's like i don't know i don't speak on
behalf of you guys but if a woman comes
to me and she's like yo i got a phd i
got this i'm like
i don't really notice those things
that's just me
you know can you be a good woman yeah i
don't know how to act like a good one
it's like
if a woman says that yeah you appreciate
it but that's not what you're looking
for
in a woman i know it's off track i know
definitely it's all practical
we're like meant to be talking about you
but romney you bring home a good point
and it again it boils down to submission
what are you submitting to are you
submitting to the creator
or are you submitting to a woman are you
submitting to something else
yeah down and you know what since we're
on the topic
i just want to drive this i want to
drive two points for him i want to one
reiterate what if i had what you said
before
if if you have a medical issue and a
doctor
prescribes like um what is it thc or
something like that mm-hmm medical
marijuana it's usually
cbd bro yeah so anything that has to
like any kind of medical marijuana or
anything like that
um even if it's out of role or anything
right if they prescribe it to you and
you need it
for certain medical purposes there's
nothing wrong with that this is the
medical condition
yeah i'm talking about recreational yeah
exactly exactly
just to drive that boy hands secondly
what was my second point man
i forgot my second point yeah we're
gonna say oh yeah oh yeah
so we say that a man should not submit
to a woman okay guys
hold up comment down below how many
times romney says bro i forgot this
oh yeah oh yeah and i think it's two
things we'll get
but like just comment down below and no
from the from episode one
he's a certified uh nutritionist
all right man just got voluntold hearts
nutritionist bro yes sir bro don't be
blaspheming
bro i want to know i went on a one week
trip i'm going to say this quick before
romney goes on
um i went on a one week trip to iceland
with with angel
and bro this man this guy told me
pretty much everything i've been eating
that i thought there was nothing wrong
with
and this guy made a whole 180 he's like
bro
you died to whack you that's off point i
gave him dawa on nutrition
he gave me down nutrition by day seven i
was like
yo i like the way this guy eats it's
just
avocados sweet potatoes and some type of
meat
it's simple
all right maybe inshallah we'll we'll
talk about that one day we'll have a
full-fledged discussion because this is
something
maybe i should book a private
consultation with
winner winner i am not a nutritionist
i'm going to win the contest online get
the consultation professionally
eyebrow go on all right yeah so i was
going to say it's not
it's not befitting i'll say especially
islamically it's not befitting for a man
to submit to a woman
all kinds of you know problems come from
that but
depending on what you mean by submit it
would actually not be wrong or bad
especially islamically for a woman to
submit to a man
because like you said a woman's nature
is more submissive
so i don't want you know any women to
hear this and be like okay
so am i a feminist am i not a feminist
do i submit do i not submit
because it depends on what you mean by
submission
not in the sense that you're like a
slave to him right and definitely not in
the sense that
yeah definitely not in the sense that
like we're slaves to allah and we submit
to him
but there is a level to it because the
prophet said i believe it's an authentic
hadith and i don't think it's disputed
but allah knows best but there's a
hadith of where the prophet sallam said
that if prostrating to anybody else
other than allah was allowed
he would command wives to prostrate to
their husbands
so islam literally aligned with her
energy
um for anyone to prostrate to anyone
other than allah and islamically
but the point is a lot of women nowadays
don't are never even put in that
situation to be in a physical position
of not prostration but submission
outside of like sex or something like
that outside of physical intimacy
so it's kind of like they wouldn't even
know that they wouldn't even know that
from experience even
because the society we grow up in it
influences things like we listen to
music and
even porn for some reason is normal and
things like cheating is known
oh my god this yeah things like that is
normal
but for you account
not not the only fans no no not this
account not this episode bro
there's a dedicated episode to that yeah
patreon
go to my bio you'll see i'm like top .05
percent of creators or some something
like that
yeah it helped them just buy a house
actually you just got a house
my subscriptions are pretty cheap though
i know that most of my demographic is
like
younger audiences so i'm not going to be
one of those those
chicks that are here charging 30 just to
see pictures of them
fully clothed eating food all right i
give you good content
so stay tuned all right
uh but yeah it would be weird
all this stuff is normal but it's weird
for a woman to even want to be a
housewife
it is especially in the west especially
in the woods
yo if y'all made it this far leave a
comment down below
housewife so we knew so we know with the
real t3mp
sorry yeah yeah for real man and i will
go as far as to say that like
and again this is completely off topic
why are we
going into this but whatever i lost bro
i'll go into it
a submissive woman isn't a woman who
prostrates to you it's a woman who's
like
who takes care of you like
she has that she has that femininity she
has that feminine energy
and she takes care of you bro as a man
what do you want you want a woman who
takes care of you
like you don't want to come home and
then this woman is just nagging your ear
off she won't cook for you
she's not like showing you any affection
anything like that why would any man in
his right mind want a woman like that
and that's all we mean by a woman being
submissive
and like if you if you had that same
example and you have a man who's in that
same position
being this way towards a woman oh man
yeah by the way i just want to say that
like just uh just
uh this is the final point insha'allah
i'm i didn't like make it up when i said
that because there's actually been
studies done that showed that
uh there's actually an article on it
about these studies and it's titled
the um the paradox of women's rights and
happiness because
naturally you think the more rights you
have the more happy you'd have the more
freedom you have so you're happier
it's actually paradoxical as they put in
the title
because the more rights women got i
think from the 70s to like
the 2000s it was over 35 years the more
rest i got the less happy they were
and they actually conducted experiments
and and interviews
with a bunch of different people and
they only got more candidates
in the thousands as the years went on
and they found that
their happiness just got lower and lower
and lower and lower with the more rights
they got
it's not even just compared to men
independent of what men experienced
compared to men yes but even
independently of what men experienced
they
saw that women over time their happiness
levels went down the more rights they
got and i'm not saying women shouldn't
have rights i'm not saying they're like
slaves or anything like that
because even in islam even slaves have
rights women are not slaves don't worry
i'm not
i'm not saying that but there's just
some food for a thought
yo this is by far the most educated
soundcloud rapper that i've met in my
life
man don't sleep on him
guys we are going to link that article
that he's talking about
that study inshallah and we'll also link
his soundcloud do not forget
subscribe to this man on soundcloud make
his dream happen y'all
we will also link the one you were
talking about
my nutritionist program no bro screw
that
the music thing frequently yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's a show and his own and you're
not linking
you ain't linking anything about
nutrition bro there's one
lucky winner who gets the number right
for the times rami
had uh memory loss and only that we
already know
[Laughter]
why would she want consultation with you
maybe she might just want to know how to
eat that's all
okay that's fair yeah i take it back i
apologize but um
bro bro
you're keeping her loud bro i mean hey
bro it's not
i didn't say anything you're you're not
halal for even thinking that i went
there
hey you can think it but you if you
don't act it then it's not it's not
um i like that bro
all right guys why don't you conclude
this
yes all right so
if you tuned in this far i don't know
how the hell you did but you did
and we uh congratulate you for that
we thank you for that it's been a
pleasure having you guys on this
completely all over the place trip that
we had today
but um yes sum it all up
if you're not submitting to the creator
you're submitting to something else and
music is it not um
they say it is and you know we can't
argue with the uh
the consensus but just
think about it for yourself cut it out
for at least a month if you're still
listening to it
you know if you still listen to it cut
it out for at least a month
see how it feels for you like fired said
how are you gonna know you have an issue
if you're not even trying anything so
cut it out and see what happens
all right but really think for yourself
understand that when you listen to music
it is making you submit you are
submitting to the music which starts to
make you dance
once you are in full submission to the
music you are in full submission to
the message that's being transmitted
whether that be vocally
whether that be in terms of frequency
but you are at the will
of the music and the rapper triple
extentation
back when i wasn't a muslim he said it
before he passed away that he could
control people how they felt
what they were thinking based on the
music that he made
so look for yourselves
if you're looking for the answers
go see them i take everything that we
say with a grain of salt
because obviously you know we are we are
on one
we are definitely all one but to
conclude the video
thank you again if you made it this far
much love
alhamdulillah
and anything else you all want to say
yeah man ladies gentlemen
there was another word used in uh
episode number four
i forgot what it was um he
tree z or whatever share the video
like the video comment it find a brother
or sister that's struggling right now
with the substance abuse problem or with
music don't tell them anything don't
attack them
just send them this be like yo this is a
dope podcast
exactly this you guys sharing this video
is the only thing that could really help
us
spread the truth all right likes yeah
people will see it
comments yeah but sharing it's like the
only way to like bring people to the
truth is to bring more people and
sharing with
your loved ones and people that respect
you right it's not every day that
you know people have you share a video
to them so when you do
they're gonna be like okay what is this
and inshallah they find the value that
you get
as well before the quotes off
no that's it for me man
i think you should close out bro you
definitely know how to close out real
nicely
i don't know how to say all the words
yet
allah
is